Hubie prized author of achievement
matters what's the title all about the
title is part of our effort the National
Urban League has spread the gospel of
achievement and make sure our children
and our parents understand that academic
achievement is more important today than
ever before
what do you mean achievement matters it
means that you've got to do well in
school in order to do well in life and
you've got to do well in school in order
to become a 21st century citizen you've
got to understand reading I mean toward
the end of the book I sort of laid out
some of the proficiencies that have
stood me in good stead over my lifetime
literacy reading curiosity critical
thinking some understanding of numeracy
some understanding of the scientific
method all of these are things that are
summoned up in various kinds of jobs
that people will he'll they're summoned
up if you're gonna run a business and
certainly if you're gonna be a citizen
in the 21st century and all of those are
the kinds of skills that are cultivated
in formal education and reinforced
through the home before we go any
farther this is for the Urban League
which you're leaving well it's it's for
parents and caregivers who are raising
children I mean what where are you going
why are you I don't well I'm leaving for
a couple of reasons first I've by the
time I leave next April it will have
been nine years I think that's a good
long run by any standard and I believe
very strongly in passing the baton of
leadership Wow
you still have your wind and before you
start to stumble and passing along a
strong organization secondly I want to
recalibrate the balance in my own
professional and personal life this year
I will have been on the road parts of 38
weeks and 19 weekends it was like that
last year and the year before that as I
look ahead it would be the same and I
want a different balance and thirdly as
I am now at 61 I feel that I've got one
more major professional challenge in me
and there probably more options at this
age then there might be four or five
years hence
where's home originally I grew up in
Washington DC I'm a product of a
wonderful family in Washington I was
born in Freedmen's Hospital in DC right
on the campus of Howard University I
grew up in a home about five or six
blocks from Howard University which was
the center of my universe when I was a
youngster I went through the public
schools I was one of the first
contingent of black students to
integrate the Washington DC Public
Schools in the aftermath
for the Brown versus Board of Education
decision in 1954 and I'd lived here up
until 1959 when I went off to college
and I sort of never experienced the
Renaissance that Washington felt once
the Kennedys arrived Washington was a
sleepy town down south when I was a kid
your parents did what my father was a
physician he was a he was a second
african-american who was board-certified
in Neurology and he had a solo practice
and he also tied with his time by
working for free at the clinics at
Howard University at the at Friedman's
hospital my mother was an activist she
was a vice president of the Americans
for democratic action back in the early
50s she's very involved in bringing the
vote to Washington DC so it was very
funny my father was a traditionalist it
didn't believe that wives should work if
if at all possible so she didn't work
she just volunteered 50 to 60 hours a
week in sync I didn't back that way but
she was very very active and we lived in
a wonderful neighborhood in Washington
my neighbors were people like Charles
Houston who was the founder of the Legal
Defense Fund double acp Legal Defense
Fund the great crusading black sports
reporters like Sam Lacey who wrote for
the african-american and really pushed
baseball to integrate so was the
glorious upbringing and I felt very
fortunate now you have how many brothers
and sisters I have one brother who's a
physician in Columbia Maryland and he's
a terrific doctor and and is my mentor
and role model sisters I have no sisters
just just one sibling and you went to
law school where I went to Yale Law
School got out in 1966 and I remember
you were like 10th out of 500 something
in your high school classes
yeah well 10 out of number 10 I over
about 700 send in the high school class
and I went to college at Amherst in
Massachusetts and then went straight on
to law school so how did your family do
so well I just a lot of drive and
determination I mean my father's father
was a farmer who died when my dad was
only three years old and he ended up
actually growing up with his first
cousin Frank Jones who was the first
African American who was board-certified
in urology in this country my dad was a
bit of a loner but he had a tremendous
amount of drive to succeed my
mother I grew up in West Haven
Connecticut and was the youngest of 10
children she also was very active she
started at Howard University where they
met and she stayed there for about a
year and then she went back to West
Haven to work in New Haven during her
young adulthood
then after both my brother and I were
born my mother went back to college at
Howard to get her BA degree in the 1940s
and she studied under Ralph Bunche and
John Hope Franklin and all of those
luminaries so I think a good deal of my
activism this was in the chromosomes
what did they do with you I mean what
what kind of things that they do with
Hugh price when it was young that got to
you all through the law school thing and
all the jobs you had well they were they
were just there to support me throughout
I'll never forget if I did something
good in school particularly it's a BK
Bruce Elementary School and it was an
awards assembly or graduation assembly
even though my father had a grueling
medical practice he would head out of
the door at the pin morning at 6:30 or 7
o'clock to go to surgery and he often
didn't get home to 9 o'clock at night if
there was an event at school he was
always there and my dad was a very
reserved man but I always knew that when
it came time for me to get an award and
go across the stage there'd be this loud
hoop of joy out in the audience and I
could look out and I could find him
because that was him so he was very
effervescent about our success my mother
was there sort of Rocksteady inspiring
us and supporting my brother and me and
they sort of set an example the other
thing is that growing up in the
segregated Washington DC in the orbit of
Howard University and in the orbit of
some and extraordinarily successful
people I grew up feeling that I could
accomplish most anything and if that
there were obstacles they were
externally imposed obstacles if there
was segregation out there was somebody
else's problem I had to overcome it by
tunneling under it blasting through it
or climbing over top of him going around
it but it was not a limitation and
internally imposed limitation on my
possibility it was externally imposed
and that was the way many of us felt and
that was the confidence that that the
Howard experience instilled in
young african-americans and in
african-american families why did you go
to Amherst
well it's interesting I was fortunate
enough to get into a number of terrific
schools one of them was Harvard
I remember going up to visit Harvard in
the early spring of my senior year and
the weather was kind of bleak and the
place looked kind of big and I said gee
this is a little off-putting now went
down to Amherst and the caliber of
education was the same I'd never played
organized sports to speak of because
high school basketball and baseball was
so good here and I figured I might have
a chance to make the basketball team at
Amherst and I actually did I beat out a
guy who was 6 feet 10 for the position
of center on our Freshman team who
couldn't even dunk that's how long ago
this was but I figured I'd get a
world-class education in a small
environment where I could do many many
more things and also it's in a
magnificent rural Sylvan setting and I
thought well I probably will never live
like this again in a setting like this
so let me just take four years out and
be in this very special place what are
the main jobs you've had in your life
well I've had eight I started out as a
legal services lawyer I was a community
activist running a group called a black
coalition of New Haven I was a an urban
affairs consultant and also a city
administrator that was up through 1978
and then we moved to New York and became
an editorial writer with the New York
Times I was like being on the faculty of
a great university is just an
incomparable experience then I went into
public television where I was with
channel 13 in New York which is the
largest public television station and I
supervised
I ran the division it produces all the
great series like great performances in
nature and American masters then moved
on to the Rockefeller Foundation as vice
president where I was in charge of grant
making and education and equal
opportunity we were able to initiate a
number of wonderful things there like
the National Commission on teaching in
America's future and what came to be
known as the National Guard Youth
Challenge core and then I moved on to
the National Urban League so I have a
little bit of a history of of trying
different things and seeing whether I
can succeed at them the National Urban
League is the longest stint I've had I
mean up until this stretch which will
last nine years I'd never been anyplace
more than six years
where
meet your wife it's interesting our
families were very very close my wife's
mother was my six my wife's aunt was my
sixth-grade teacher and her uncle was my
sponsor and mentor for Amherst College a
distinguished graduate of Amherst by the
name of dr. Montague Cobb my father had
operated on my wife's grandfather or
grandmother but we didn't meet until
college when I was at Amherst and she
was at Mount Holyoke and we dated a bit
my first year she was a year ahead of me
a little bit his same age and then we
then she went off to junior year abroad
and and we didn't really date and then
once she got back we started seeing each
other again and the romance was ignited
and we got married 1963 so we're coming
up on 39 years of marriage has she had a
profession yes she said that worked with
a world class organization called a
manpower demonstration Research
Corporation which is the premier
organization that does social science
experiments for example running job
training programs and education programs
and then submitting the results to a
rigorous analysis she's been with them
since about 1979 so she had a great
great career with them three daughters
yep how old are they today well they're
they're all turning over this this fall
one will be 31 one will be 33 in the
other will be 38 and what had they done
what's interesting our youngest daughter
Lauren is a development associate with
the new victory theatre complex up in
New York it's a great great institution
and she's learning a lot and enjoying it
our middle daughter like me lasted in
the law about two years and she has
reinvented herself as a public radio
producer so she's a producer on a show
called on the media that's nationally
syndicated over NPR and her name is
Janine and our eldest starter Traer is a
choreographer of water fountains if you
were to go to the Bellagio Hotel in Las
Vegas and see those magnificent water
displays out there she choreographed
several of those numbers and she's also
choreographed some of the splash tacular
numbers out in front of the geodesic
dome at Epcot Center still weren't
married and
and her husband is a set designer and
writer so what did you do with those
three girls in your family that ends up
in this book well there a number of
stories from their life experience
that's interesting for example one of
the main points of the book is that you
should start to read to your children
from the very earliest stage even before
they can read to you as I was describing
at that point to my eldest daughter that
it was gonna be in the book a bemused
look came over her face and she said I
still remember to this day how you and
mom used to park yourselves on my pillow
at night when I was this big and read to
me every night and so I grew up knowing
that this thing called reading must
should become important to me if it was
that important to you in the book we
talked about the importance of keeping a
close eye on how much television kids
watched it's children who watched three
and four hours of television a night
tend not to read nearly as well as kids
who only watch an hour or less and I
thought back to my own experience and
how my wife had an ironclad rule that
our children could not watch more than
an hour television a day they would take
their best shot but that was it
and to further deepen the sort of the
anecdotal part of the book I recounted
how when we were living in New Haven
Connecticut in a kind of inner-city
neighborhood in our house kept getting
broken into and our TVs were stolen I
went out and bought a used floor model
TV figure nobody would steal that or
else they'd get a hernia but it would
invariably break and we decided not to
replace it because I'm afraid it might
get stolen and we found that within a
couple of days our children were fine
they were reading more playing more
games interacting more with us and with
themselves and our tea our household
would be without a television for months
and months and months on end and frankly
it was me who was wanted to watch the
NBA playoffs that always will break down
and go out and buy a TV set but I
learned a basic lesson there about the
importance of containing the amount of
television that children watch because
all sorts of other opportunities and
interests blossom as a result of that
you say in your book that black kids
watch what an hour or more television a
day than white kids you
there I mean the this the patterns of
television what's happened is that a lot
of parents are working extraordinarily
hard and don't have a whole web backup
resources
sort of back into using television as an
electronic babysitter and it's it's easy
to understand how that can happen it's
easy to understand how much of a
struggle it's or wrestle with your
children over how much they watch but
it's critically important to curb the
amount of TV they watch and make sure
that they read for fun play games and
involved in stimulating activities why
black kids more than white kids I think
they're just maybe more single-parent
households in our communities so they're
fewer parents around to keep an eye on
the situation and to monitoring how do
you get around that well I think we've
got a share message that there are other
ways in which youngsters can can
function and can engage themselves and
and one of the points of saying we went
for months on end without a TV is that
you know the children really do survive
quite well with without it just as they
survived before television was ever
invented and we ought to do that and
even if you had have to pull the plug
even if you have to break the television
don't let them become addicted to it the
Urban League is what the Urban League is
the oldest and largest community-based
movement empowering African Americans to
enter the economic and social mainstream
we were founded in 1910
that's essentially been what we've been
about our entire history and the heart
of our Urban League movement is our more
than 100 professionally staffed
affiliates all over the United States
how many people work for their
everything you know I wish I had that
number but the typical affiliate we have
about a hundred and twenty at the
National Urban League office and I'd say
a typical robust affiliate probably have
fifty to a hundred people working for it
some of our smaller ones might have
staffs of five or six how much does the
national organization spend a year our
budgets about forty two million dollars
a year roughly 1/4 of that is general
operating support and the balances
grants and to the individual groups
around the country have to raise our own
money oh yeah oh yeah yeah they're very
robust them it makes our movement a very
interesting one because we provide
leadership at the national level but we
don't have a command control environment
we have what I call a kajol environment
and we try to get everybody on the page
around a certain
of things but they also have to be very
responsive to local imperatives and
local needs and increasingly with the
decentralization of federal funding
they've had a much greater burden of
raising resources on their own where
does your money come from a variety of
sources we get some government grants we
get quite a few foundation grants we
have major strategic partnerships with
corporations we have fundraising events
like our annual dinners and we're
increasingly getting into the direct
mail individual giving realm of all the
things you do what's your personal
favorite program you think's the most
important thing that the Urban League
does well I've been obsessed with our
whole campaign for African American
achievement because I think that
ensuring that our children do well
academically and become enthusiastic
lifetime learners is hugely important to
their long-term success as providers and
as citizens of of the United States and
of the world so we've moved beyond
thinking just about a direct service you
know what kind of program can we operate
in to a broad community mobilization
modality where we are spreading the
gospel of academic achievement through
PSAs on urban radio where we've teamed
up with scholastic magazine to create a
guide called read and rise we've already
for parents and the specific things they
can do and we've already gotten grants
to print up 1.75 million copies of that
guide we have created a national
achiever Society it's a community based
Honor Society for kids who are doing
well in school and earning B averages
are better in school
we've inducted more than 25 thousand
children into that program since it got
started and in some places for example a
year and a half ago I was out at the San
Diego Urban League and we were at
Bayview Baptist Church on a Saturday
afternoon in June we inducted 350
youngsters black youngsters all of whom
had B averages of better and half of
whom were boys that was a thrilling
sight to behold and there were 800
parents in the church the church was so
full that parents were sitting in the
pews reserved for the choir so we had
1100 people out on a Saturday afternoon
for about two and a half hours to
celebrate achievement that just brings
goose you know makes it makes makes your
skin just
it's just so exciting it's like I can't
even describe it it's just this the
thrilling sight and that's happening all
over the country so I think we've helped
transform children's attitudes toward
academic achievement and and to
transform parents attitudes and the
whole point of the book was to provide
these kinds of inspiring stories and
specific tons of tips that parents can
use to help their children become
proficient readers and high achievers
and that I think is a signature
accomplishment that's happened on my
watch who was it that created the
program were a youngster if they read 50
books a year something like that could
get a free bicycle right that was ronald
ross who was the superintendent of
schools in Mount Vernon New York just
outside New York City Ron came into the
schools in the school system in Mount
Vernon in the late 1990s 35 33 % of the
youngsters in the schools were passing
the New York State Exam in the fourth
grade
by the time he left earlier this year 79
percent of the kids were passing it was
an extraordinary exponential growth in
reading proficiency that he orchestrated
I'm delighted to say Ron is now a
distinguished fellow with the National
Urban League and we're providing him
with a national platform to spread his
knowledge and his inspiring stories to
school districts all over the country
somewhere over the years I've read a
statistic that 70% of the black bursar
out of wedlock is that accurate
it's been that high than what what's
very encouraging now is the fact that
the out of wedlock birth rate among
black teenagers is that a 40-year low so
the trends are reversing themselves and
we're really really pleased with that
because I think our youngsters are
beginning to absorb the message that if
you have a baby when you're a teenager
and you don't have your own high school
degree and you're not married then the
overwhelming odds are that your child
will spend some time of her his life in
poverty but if you wait until after
you're married until after you have
gotten your high school diploma and
after age 21 the odds are that your
children will never be poor and I think
our kids are beginning to absorb that
message that's very important what's
causing the low after all these 40 years
well I suspect several things I think
that probably welfare reform
has made it very clear to kids that
there won't be a lifetime on welfare if
you have a child I think that at least
in the latter part of the 90s a strong
economy was pulling youngsters into the
workforce I think our message that
achievement matters has made a big
difference and frankly I suspect that
fear of sexually transmitted diseases
especially potentially fatal ones like
AIDS has had a sobering impact on kids
when President Clinton signed the bill
to change welfare reform where was your
position on that
we're very disturbed by it we believe
very strongly that people should work in
everyone who possibly can should work
but we're worried about the
inflexibility of the five-year time
limits because there could come a time
and we're actually in it now well
there's what might be called a perfect
economic storm a lull in the economy a
recession which has strapped state so
that they barely have money to provide
on an extended unemployment benefits and
rigid welfare time limits now I'm very
worried that a lot of families are being
pushed back on the welfare and if they
hit those time limits and the
unemployment benefits have run out then
where are they going to be you know
there's a surge in homelessness we're
seeing around the country I think it's
got something to do with that we're
seeing a surge in the patronage of food
pantries I think it's got something to
do with that we don't see a lot of data
about this and politicians don't want to
talk about it but we are in a situation
now with a combination of time limits
financially strapped States and a
sluggish labor market that made the
rigidity of welfare reform really
frightening and that that that was our
worry all along and I think we're now
seeing that that can actually come to
pass did you suggest in your book that
one of the things that came out of
welfare reform or that kids were home in
the afternoon with the mothers working
now and they weren't getting care no I
mean that's been a pattern all along and
whether people are on welfare or not the
fact is that a lot of folks are out of
the home and that's true in in all
families and so after-school programs
for youngsters of all ages are
critically important I mean I think we
need to look at running schools much
longer than we do wouldn't bother me if
they opened up at 7:30 in the morning
and went till 6 o'clock in the evening I
mean that's what prep schools do that's
what a lot of private schools
do we know from research that
after-school youth development programs
help to promote academic achievement and
curb mischievous behavior and criminal
activity and curbed out of wedlock teen
sex so given how effective after-school
programs are they should be part of the
everyday life of youngsters have you
studied another issue because you talk
about black men in here start was that
third grade seems to be a big challenge
mysterious phenomenon the third grade I
don't fully understand it I'm not an
educator but I know that we've got to
keep an eye out and that is that a lot
of youngsters particularly black males I
start off on a pretty good path in
school but around the third or fourth
grade they start to slip off us slide
back and if you're not careful you can
look up in a year or two and find the
children are way way behind and then
you've got a lot of heavy-duty catching
up to do so the point of the book is
that parents should walk watch this
phenomenon like a hawk and they need to
be in close contact with the teachers
and making sure that teachers tell them
if there's any sign of slippage they
need to be monitoring report cards going
to the meet the teacher nights and just
staying on that very very close because
if you can get your youngster through
that period chances are they'll stay
pretty much on course to the rest of the
way and it's one of the major points in
the book and it's why parent engagement
is so critically important a lot of
parents have said to me when I was on
the book tour well you know I've got
I've got to deal with food clothing and
shelter why can't I just trust the
teachers where I can I just trust the
schools and the reason is that sometimes
there's slippage in the schools aren't
letting you know that secondly even if
they are letting you know that you've
got to be locked in and really
monitoring the situation very very
closely and thirdly sometimes the
educators make judgements about your
kids that really are not appropriate
they may want to refer your child of
special education when if you got a
second opinion you'd find that that's
really not necessary or they may miss
read the potential of a youngster I mean
I had that happen to me when I was
growing up here in Washington DC when I
was at Coolidge high school during the
summer between my junior and senior
years I was fortunate to be chosen for a
program for students were very strong in
math and science
and that summer when we were working in
that job we were given a test about to
help assess our future potential I will
never in life forget being called in for
the results and being told at age 16
even though I was ranked number 10 in my
high school class of 700 that I probably
would get to go to college but that I
should never count on going to graduate
school or professional school now my
parents bless him when I ran home and
told them that's what I'd been told they
said don't pay any attention to it we're
gonna keep honor that's one of the
reasons my parents were so fantastic
because they had a sense of what my
possibilities were and they stuck with
me but can you imagine if a child didn't
tell a parent that or if a parent to
sort of dismiss the information and
those are people who ostensibly were
well intentioned but they totally
misread me or they had worse intentions
in mind perhaps they weren't well
intentioned but the point is that I was
given an assessment of my potential
which was way below what I was capable
of achieving and had I internalized that
in behave accordingly it would have been
a real shame but she said you you
interfered with your own daughter who
the school was messing with the Honors
Program yeah I mean it was interesting
when we tried to register our daughter
in the honors program wanting the best
for her what said he by the way for this
was in New Rochelle on New York right
after we we moved in 1978 they didn't
place her where we felt she should be
placed and I went in to see them and
it's very big deal for black fathers to
come to the school and I talked to the
teachers and they the teacher gave me
two reasons it first was well you they
said I should be very pleased with where
she was placed she'll be well served and
in fact they were telling me don't
question their judgment and I said well
I know my daughter is capable of much
more so I'm gonna question your judgment
and I want it turned around secondly
they said to me you all have just moved
to town and there's a list this long of
kids who are eager to get into the
Honors Program and it's wrong for you to
leapfrog the list and I sort of
apologize for being pushy but I said I
don't care my daughter belongs in honors
and that's where I'm gonna do my level
best to make sure she's in but the moral
of that story was that there was a list
this long
youngsters who wanted the very best at
the schools could offer yet the school
was only it was husbanding the very best
for only a handful and that's wrong in
the 21st century where we have to
develop all young people to their
fullest potential and so I told them I
said well I'm gonna call the
superintendent tomorrow morning and
we'll get this straightened out before I
could place the call they call the house
to say that she had been reassigned
do they ever then is there ever a
backlash on your daughter after the dads
been there you know there's a risk of
that but that's why you've got to stay
on it and just tell me not gonna
tolerate it you made a statement that
it's a big deal for black fathers to
show up at a school why well I think you
know unfortunately aren't as many black
father's on the scene in families as
we'd like
they aren't it often is engaged in the
schools as they ought to be I think that
when black ground fathers come to the
school sends a very powerful signal
their momma and daddy are on this and
actually parents then if both are more
engaged can do a tag team so that that
it isn't the mother that's always got to
go there it was very important when I
would go to the meet the teacher nights
out at in the schools in nourish oh I'd
see a lot of fathers there so the the
teachers knew that the parents the
family was on the case and that's very
important and the children knew that
this was enormous ly important to both
parents I mean to go back to the story
of my father coming to those assemblies
he couldn't come to all the things that
happen in the school but I knew that
when it really really mattered he was
there and that meant a great deal to me
have you ever studied the never there's
30-some black folks in the United States
how many of situations where they don't
have parents kids don't have birth yeah
but and the families are many of the
families are extraordinarily resilient I
mean there are resilient grandparents
aunts and uncles who are doing a great
job I mean one of the points of the book
and one of the things I think makes it
very accessible is that we talk to a lot
of youngsters in our national achiever
society and we talk to their parents and
grandparents who are raising them and
resilient folks make all sorts of
adjustments in order to go from here to
there and and a fundamental message of
the book is that we have to have the
will to ensure that
children succeed and secondly we have to
have the mother whip and the mother wit
basically says I'm going to make sure my
child gets educated come hell or high
water if I can't figure this out myself
I'm gonna find help if there isn't a
relative who can help me with a part of
this that I don't understand then I'm
gonna go talk to the pastor but the
point is I'm gonna move my child from
here to there I know which end is up and
and we're going there and I'm gonna do
whatever is necessary their words
wonderful stories of dr. ben Carson the
fantastic neurosurgeon who talks about
how when he was a child his his mother
was basically illiterate I think and yet
she knew that having the children hid
you know the kids read to her was
critically important Vernon Jarret the
distinguished black journalist talks
about how his grandfather used to have
he and his brother read to him the
grandfather was stone-cold illiterate
and but he said I want you to sit down
and I want you to read and when they'd
finished reading a page the grandfather
would say you got that sentence over
there wrong read it again
my father didn't know whether the
sentence was right or wrong but he knew
that getting them to practice reading
was important that's mother with
grandfather wit so the combination of
will and mother wit is what has
propelled a lot of young people to
success when things go wrong what causes
it in your opinion young kids well I
think that a lot of young kids are
growing up in neighborhoods and in
families where things have not gone well
for the adults the adults become very
skeptical about whether the system will
ever work for them and they impart that
skepticism lack of confidence to the
children I think that there's a lot of
chaos in some families violence that can
throw the children off and a lot of
times the kids in those kinds of
environments turn to alternatives like
the gangs that have a lot of structure
an alternative formulation of what it
means to be successful in the children
get sucked into that so there are a lot
of very difficult conditions that kids
are being reared in there are some
extraordinary many millions of
extraordinarily resilient adults who are
successful and know which end is up in
spite of that but it takes a strong
adult to know that the other thing that
happens is I think that you find schools
and teachers in some situations who
don't believe in the possibility
of the children I'm on the board of
Metropolitan Life Insurance Company and
they do an annual survey education
survey and a couple years ago they
surveyed a lot of urban teachers in a
lot of urban school children and the
when they surveyed the teachers the
teachers felt that only about a third a
third of the kids they teach are likely
to go to college when they surveyed the
children two-thirds of them expect to go
to college that's a massive expectations
gap if the doubts that the educators
have about the children are imparted to
the children that injects doubt unless
the children have a lot of reinforcement
from parents who can say in spite of
this we're moving forward you say you're
against vouchers but for charter schools
right I think that having lots of
different kinds of public schools
available to kids that are different
sizes different themes schools where
principals have more flexibility to put
together the faculty team that they want
is a good thing for the schools I think
that kind of public those kinds of
options within a public system and that
kind of accountability within the public
system make a great deal of sense
vouchers frightened me for several
reasons and I understand if we were
looking eye to eye at a parent whose
child is trapped in a lousy school why a
parent would want an alternative and I
I'd be the last one to say you shouldn't
want that but when you look at the big
picture
vultures are often framed as an option
for low income parents whose children
are in lousy schools but in very short
order given the politics of this country
there's inevitable pressure to
universalize a windfall like that and I
can imagine
parents who's already send their
children to parochial schools synagogues
schools Muslim schools Baptist schools
saying we're hardworking Americans we
want the best for our kids why should we
be cut out of this windfall I can
imagine home schoolers saying I'm doing
the job myself why should I pay taxes
give me some of my money back and I can
imagine people saying why should those
low income kids just get this benefit
that's class warfare let's make it
available to everyone why should mostly
minority kids get these benefits that's
racial preferences
quotas let's make it available to
everyone once that pressure to
universalize the benefit kicks in and
we're already seeing signs of it the
cost of financing that alternative
whether through the tax code of direct
appropriations becomes astronomical and
the bill will be paid it will be drawn
on the account of the appropriations for
public education it will not come out of
the prison budget it will not come out
of the highway budget and that really
could devastate public education so I
think we've got to focus on making the
public schools work better and not
finance the exit of those who are
disgruntled did you ever feel that you
were somebody's quota not in the least I
mean I understand the consideration of a
variety of factors and I know that
Amherst for example wanted to have some
african-american students I was there
during the year or when they weren't an
awful lot but there were some there was
affirmative action for white students
when I was in college I mean there
weren't enough black students on campus
for there to be affirmative action but
many of the great schools the highly
selective schools wanted to be sure that
not all of their kids came from New York
and Boston the ones on the East Coast
and then out all the kids came from
private schools like Andover and Exeter
so they didn't just pick from the top
according to the numbers on the SAT
exams they said we want capable kids
with lots of potential who come from the
south white kids who come from the south
from the Rocky Mountain States from the
far west from the Dakotas and so they
managed their admissions procedure in
the consideration of merit to ensure
that there was diversity among white
students I think that's fine
and I think we need to do that for all
students in the 21st century so I think
we need a robust commitment to inclusion
in our society the demographics are
driving us in that direction I think
we've got to be sure that all kids who
are considered are meritorious but the
notion that you only pick based on
quantitative factors like test scores
and grades is wrongheaded you write the
following you say I know that America
hasn't gotten rid of racism and
discrimination everywhere in the land I
know that many public schools don't
educate minority children nearly as well
as they should but I beg you please
don't use racism as a reason why you
won't do your level
to make sure your child becomes a good
reader have you heard somebody do that
well there there are people who say you
know I don't believe in the system the
system is never gonna give me a shot
yeah I've gotten those kinds of calls on
radio people who are so fed up with or
who have given up and who won't engage
therefore and they say you know if it's
not gonna work for me
it probably won't work for my kid so
maybe I don't have the time or energy to
invest it there are folks who are sort
of really depressed probably bordering
on a clinical depression about sort of
the struggle to succeed if you're
growing up in the heart of the inner
city but we can't succumb to that the
slaves didn't succumb to it the Freedom
Riders didn't succumb to it
the people who were part of the civil
rights movement didn't succumb to it and
we can't succumb today because then
that's a recipe for chronic poverty
depression and isolation from the
mainstream and the point of the book is
there so many stories of resilient
people who know which end is up who are
just as poor who have mustered the
energy and the will to be successful and
that's what we almost did talk a lot
about reading as we have already named
several books three or four books that
you've always trying to be your favorite
well the most wonderful novel I've read
in the last 10 years is snow falling on
Cedars I just I just can't get over that
book I think it's a truly extraordinary
book I've started in Robert Caro's most
recent biography of Lyndon Johnson which
is quite remarkable I I vacillate
between sort of airplane reading very
light novels a lot of the stuff by James
Patterson I've gotten into Richard North
Patterson's works recently his book I
think it was a protect and defend I
think was a lot of fun in that in that
vein and then I then I go into fictional
biography Colin Powell's biography was
was very moving for me and to say that
the new biography and Lyndon Johnson the
biography of by David Reverend Lewis of
WB Dubois the two volumes extraordinary
histories a couple of others that are
read that over the years that I was very
moved by Kenneth man
wrote a book called black Apollo science
which is a story of earnest ever just
and Martin Duberman wrote a biography of
Paul Robeson and those two were
biographies were remarkable for me
because they they were the stories of of
men of outsized talent and ambition who
were confined by segregation they pushed
against the wall of segregation so hard
they ended up almost losing their
balance and both our Greek tragedies but
amazingly attractive brilliant men who
were ahead of their time who would be
just superstars in American society
today and the stories are so engaging a
matter of fact when I was in public
television heading up the division that
produces great performances we were so
interested in both of those books that
we tried to get the rights to do draw
international co-productions based on
them because there's such compelling
American stories so I I move between
fiction and nonfiction and very light
fiction how much how much do you read I
probably read a book every other week
depends on how much I'm flying if I fly
a lot then I'll consume more books right
now I've got them carrying around the
the biography of Frida Kahlo my wife and
I saw that new film absolutely loved it
and she and Diego Rivera and amazing
characters and I wanted to know more
about them so I bought the book it's
pretty thick and I'm cutting it around
with me you're there reference from time
to time about blacks and entertainment
and blacks and sports and then take
someone like yourself if you had us top
sports figure a top music figure and
Hugh price standing there which one do
you think the kids would go for as a
mentor well I think a couple years ago
obviously they'd gravitate toward the
athlete and the Glitter and and you know
probably some of the rock stars
I think after 9/11 there's been
interesting transformation and with the
way we think about heroism and I think
we've rediscovered everyday heroes and
the nobility of everyday life with the
celebration of the heroism of not just
the firefighters and the policemen but
the emergency workers who carried people
out the office workers who carried
people on the flight attendants on the
plain so I think something very healthy
has happened in that we have
rediscovered more accessible heroes
because we've got to let our young
people know that there's dignity in
everyday life in this heroism in
everyday life and I think that's that if
there's one good thing and it's probably
about the only good thing that's come up
9/11 it is it is that I mean you
actually see kids treating you
differently than they used to
yeah I mean we do these national
induction national achievers society
induction ceremonies that kids are out
there by the hundreds yeah they're
they're very interested in the real
world now much more rooted in real world
I mean the the the the the the hero I
worship the most among this celebrities
was Jackie Robinson when I was growing
up Jackie wasn't God he wasn't just a
superstar and I I was blessed to meet
him when I was nine years old and had my
picture taken with and I thought I was
having my picture taken with God because
of not only the physical accomplishments
but the the the bravery of the man
just an amazing man Janie Victoria Ward
you quote from author of the skin where
we're in teaching our children to be
emotionally strong socially smart and
spiritually connected what I'm getting
at is here she's suggesting that
visiting museums libraries attending
lectures and plays because the parents
feel those activities are too white yeah
what is that all about well I mean we've
just got to work on her parents about
that I think it's a little bit of a
function of time and not a whole lot of
exposure on the part of the parents but
in the book I talk about what can happen
when you visit a museum we took a bunch
of young people that I'm part of a group
that mentors the Westchester Club and
these black kids in elementary school up
in White Plains and all boys and we took
them to the Metropolitan Museum of Art
so that they could have a highbrow heart
experience and a couple of the kids were
into the the the paintings and such but
most of the boys weren't as we walk down
one of the corridors the kids spotted
the armor out of the corner of their eye
the testosterone
pump kicked on and they made a beeline
for the armor and there their noses were
smashed up against the glass trying to
read all the captions about the
crossbows and
muskets and all that all that hardware
had we had the presence of mind then and
what we certainly should do today is we
should have said you guys are in the
armor tomorrow let's go to the library
but let's go online and let's see what
you can discover about armor had they
done that think about they could have
learned a lot about the great religions
and the Crusades they could have learned
about the evolving geography of Europe
and how that's impacted the rest of the
world they could have learned some
science the metallurgy of how that stuff
is made they could learn some math I
mean how far would the shaft of a
crossbow
go if you pull it down against a certain
potential strength on the bow etc a lot
of the disciplines that are studied in
school could have been reinforced just
by that moment of exposure in a an
enrichment program I mean if you're deep
into baseball III as a kid used to I
thought I was gonna become a major
league baseball player and I was 15
before I realized it wasn't gonna happen
although all the pitchers who threw
curveballs that I couldn't hit and do it
over Friday but when I was in elementary
school I devoured baseball magazines and
I started out reading baseball magazines
for elementary school kids were pretty
soon I could read them for any age group
I learned that if you figure out how to
calculate a batting average in an earned
run average you've got long division
down cold but the point is you need to
look for where the light bulb goes off
where the spark appears and for the kids
who are in the museum with us it was the
armor and then all the standard stuff
that goes on in school could have been
reinforced by letting them explore their
newfound curiosity about this that can
happen in all sorts of environments
music the arts sports any number of
these places and I one of the things I
wish is that formal education were more
flexible so that when the light bulb
goes off they can develop a full
curricular and discovery experience
around it why do you think they're
interested armor what is it in the
society that draws them that well I mean
this is this I I wish I was enough of a
psychologist to say but there's that
there are things that boys are more
interested in than girls probably I hate
to say it I don't have a more
sophisticated understanding of
the net boys are probably more
interested in football than girls more
interested in certain kinds of contact
sports and girls I don't know but there
there was something about the the armor
and making war and all that kind of
stuff that that intrigued them and I
just know that they were drawn to it
you mentioned the West Chester the club
right what is it well there's a
wonderful group of african-american
professional men in West Chester called
the West Chester Clubman it was founded
some probably close to 40 years ago that
people had kept Callaway and Sidney
portait was in and it's doctors and
lawyers and others one of the things we
do is we each put up a substantial
amount of money a year to support an
after-school program for kids who are
struggling in school and that group is
called the club spawned by the West
Chester club men and we take those young
people and they they are in this program
every day after school for about three
hours they work on their homework we
then have enrichment programs for them
take them on trips we've taken them to
museums to the Wonderful's
Science Museum in New Jersey we've taken
them to West Point we've taken them to
auto shows I mean we've done all sorts
of things with them but the point is to
provide the kind of after-school support
that reinforces and supports both their
academic development in their social
development some of them have been taken
invited to visit us I had one of the
young people shadow me at the National
Urban League for a day they've saddled
some of the doctors in the organization
when I was at channel 13 we took a group
of the young people down to our studios
and to our editing Suites at channel 13
and it was great for them to see
african-americans women and men
everyplace in the studio they were on
camera they were behind the camera they
were in the editing Suites I mean one of
the greatest moments was when a
different of mine by the name of George
Miles who was executive vice president
station and is now the head of the
Pittsburgh public television station
George came out George about 63 and kind
of gruff sound and grew up in their
project looks a lot like Paul Robeson's
son actually had teased him about that
and George said to the kids he said when
I was growing or just a CPA he said when
I was growing up if anybody ever told me
I wasn't capable of doing something that
was
what I was gonna do and I was gonna
Shawn and he said they told me you
couldn't do this and do that and that
was exactly what I decided to show them
I could I could do and Excel it and to
see those kids react to that and to be
inspired where that was wonderful so we
try to expose them to people like George
and others who are extraordinarily
accomplished whose life circumstances in
the beginning were very similar and who
have climbed up and climbed to the top
and that's one of the beauties of a
well-conceived after-school program by
the way before we run out of time you're
leaving the Urban League in April what's
your next career I don't have anything
lined up there are sectors that I would
find potentially quite interesting I
think higher education is potentially
quite interested in the corporate world
the right portfolio could be interesting
something in philanthropy and maybe
media pundit REE I don't know I hope
something will present itself I have
pursued a couple of careers in my life
quite aggressively neither panned out in
both instances I think my lucky stars
within six months they didn't happen all
the situations I've been blessed to
pursue professionally have sort of
presented themselves and I trust my
instinct as to whether they're right for
me the Rockefeller Foundation you also
at the New York Times editorial board
public television public television of
all those which one did you really enjoy
the most I've enjoyed every one of them
I've never not enjoyed a career I can't
I can't do something professionally if I
don't want to get up in the morning and
do it and I go flat out when I do it so
they've they've all been fantastic
experiences they've all built on one
another my position that the National
Urban League is CEO has been has enabled
me to draw on all of those careers I
liken being the head of the National
Urban League to an applied liberal arts
course because everything you ever
learned and I ever learned in freshman
college freshman year at Amherst is in
play there so I've I've just had a
terrific time at everything I've ever
done if you had to name one thing that
you would remember as something he
learned at these places that start with
the New York Times editorial board what
would it be what you take away from
there you didn't know before well I
remember when I was getting sick of
writing the same editorial the same
theme same topic about ten times I went
in to see max Frankel who was the head
of the page at the time and I said I'm
really tired of this
they must have gotten the point by now
and Mac said what makes you think they
read it the first time what makes you
think they've absorbed the message what
makes you think they've changed their
behavior go back and write it you've got
to write it and write it and write it
until you're blue in the face
so that was a basic lesson from the
Rockefeller but from the New York Times
about imparting a message if you really
believe in it the Rockefeller Foundation
that was a marvelous experience because
we got to create things and to use the
Foundation's money to do that as I look
back on the National Guard Youth
Challenge Corps when I went in to see
the head of the National Guard in the
spring of 1989 and said you know the
military used to be a tremendous outlet
for kids who had lost their way and you
all stopped doing that
would you consider starting a domestic
youth corps for kids who dropped out of
school and the moment of Revelation was
when they said you know we think of
ourselves as youth workers we just train
him to make war but I didn't realize
that the military invest more on
understanding human development and then
the other institution on earth and that
conversation sparked it ignited their
interest in what came to be known as the
National Guard Youth Challenge Corps
which was started in the early 90s exist
to this day and has been tremendously
successful in getting dropouts back on
track what did you gain from or learn
from public television I'm just the
power of communications just the
absolute power of communications and the
power of reflective communications and
one of the things that I'm troubled by
is the superficiality of so much
coverage these days the entertainment
value that's been injected into the news
and and I have tremendous respect for
public television and public radio
because they they dare to take a longer
look at issues they dare to be more
reflective about the issues we can't
afford in a 21st century to get our news
from the news crawls we've got to crawl
behind the news and understand develop a
deeper understanding of what's at stake
and that has been the signature of
c-span it's the signature of public
television it's a signature of public
radio and I I think we've got to
preserve those values and then finally
the Urban League well I just I was I've
been blessed to work with
and to survey a great movement when I
was a young professional doing
consulting work I got to meet Whitney
Young Vernon Jordan John Jacob who my
predecessors and and I wanted to be like
them and I got to fulfill that dream I
got to serve a movement that's now
almost 93 years old that has helped
propel people into the American
mainstream professionally it doesn't get
much better than that fulfilling a dream
and being able to lead a great movement
on page 51 you have something called the
pledge of the national achievers Society
I want to read it I am excellent I am
excellent I am excellent my mind is a
pearl I can do anything anything that my
mind can conceive I can achieve anything
that my mind can conceive and my heart
can believe I can achieve I am excellent
I am excellent I am a national achiever
what's that all about
you'd have to be in a church in hearing
350 kids say then that's about a mindset
instilling and reinforcing a mindset
getting children to express their
commitment to their own excellence enter
their own possibilities we are trying to
spread that gospel of achievement
throughout our community and having
youngsters say that openly in front of
800 adults is very very affirming for
the kids it's very affirming for the
parents and it lays the foundation for
taking achievement truly seriously in
our entire community I mean I once said
to Mayor Mike Bloomberg that I think our
achiever society does fantastic thing
but I'd love to see a parade down Fifth
Avenue for all the kids who are doing
well in school or down Pennsylvania
Avenue in Washington or down Michigan
Avenue in Chicago and let the kids who
are doing well in school
march in that parade with their parents
on one hand and their teachers on the
other that's when we will really start
to impact the way our children see their
possibilities and the priorities that
they set for themselves can you remember
a program that you either had at the
Urban League or someplace else that you
decided this does not work and abandon
it well I think what we've done is by
trying to focus we have winnowed some
things I mean we're now about to get
more involved in help than we had
but we scaled back our health activities
for a while we were I I'd have to think
harder about that I don't know I don't
know one doesn't come instantly to mind
who walked around the block one of my
colleagues at the National Urban League
a mother who's who lives in Philadelphia
and she's got a grueling commute from
Philly to New York and back every day
and when she gets home she walks around
the block with her child and she knows
that her child says let's walk around
again or if she's really tired doesn't
want to go around the block and the
daughter says mom we need to take a walk
there's something that John wants to
talk about it's a very very powerful
message very interesting do you do
anything as a mentor that you know
always works you can see it kids change
I think when you lock in on a kid and
let them know you really are interested
in them that you're really listening to
them and you want to help them unlock
their own potential that's that's
incredibly gratifying whether it's with
your own children or with a young person
that you're mentoring and and in the
book I talked about a youngster who was
sort of half asleep and the in the club
program one day and we came in and and I
asked what he'd been doing in school and
he muttered that they were supposed to
do something about writing editorials
and I said that you know I used to be an
editorial writer and so one eye popped
open and I asked him how do you go about
writing editorials and he sort of came
up to a 25 degree angle and before we
were done he was sitting bolt upright
and we were fully engaged and this was a
kid who looked at me as a suit and a tie
and it was obviously dialed out but by
the time we were done that day we were
locked in his mother came up to me in a
Barnes & Noble book store about a year
ago and said do you remember him his
name was definite just I do you remember
him I said yeah very vividly said
Devin's just about to finish his junior
year in college and he's studying to be
a physical therapist this is a kid who
was sort of half asleep disconnected
could care less so when you see that and
and you've made that connect and can
look back on
the time when you may have ignited a
spark it's very exciting when did you
take away from the book to her the
probably the fundamental message was the
question I kept being asked by parents
that come to the bookstores in the
african-american community it's all I
can do to provide food clothing and
shelter why can't why can't I just trust
the teachers and the message of the book
is that you can't just trust the
teachers ronald reagan's politics were
never my politics but he said of nuclear
disarmament who must trust but verify in
other words there are matters of
enormous importance you must trust but
verify so it reinforced the fact that
I've got to keep explaining to folks why
I know how busy you are but you've got
to get engaged for all the reasons that
we talked about in the book you've got
to monitor what's going on you got to be
sure that what the teachers are doing is
in the best interest of your child and
you've got to let the schools know and
the kids know that you're on the case
you can't just trust you must trust but
verify this is the cover of the book
it's called achievement matters by Hubie
price the outgoing president of the
National Urban League we thank you very
much thank you my pleasure